foreign
leader just got out of that enormous
yellow tractor that you can see behind
him as he drove up the street there
given quite a warm reception there he is
launching the liberal Democrats uh local
uh Council election campaign today uh
lots and lots of the Dem supporters uh
there with them I think we can show you
that arrival moment
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
and he's speaking so let's listen in
and I brought my tractor along
[Applause]
I need some heavy machinery to clear up
the mess of the conservatives
I'm
wherever I go in this campaign I've been
going up and down the country I've been
going to Villages towns and cities
and wherever I go I see the incredible
natural beauty of our country
and I see the decency and strength of
the British people
and even in these incredibly difficult
times the toughest of times
people are working hard they're raising
their families they're playing by the
rules
but they're finding it harder and harder
just to make ends meet
and you know they are struggling and the
cost of living is really hitting them
hard
and what they need more than ever is a
fair deal yeah
but the conservative government is
letting people down badly
taking people for granted yeah
and when you look at people's energy
Bills going through the roof they're
food bills the housing costs
millions of families and pensioners are
struggling like never before
but the conservatives have made this
cost of living crisis even worse with
their total chaos
they crash the economy adding hundreds
of pounds to people's monthly mortgage
payments and they've compounded that
with unfair tax Rises and cuts to
essential Public Services paying for the
damage that they caught in the first
place
and then when it comes to the NHS
letting the NHS crisis spiral out of
control
breaking their promises to build new
hospitals
failing to recruit the 6 000 doctors
they promised to the last election
and people are suffering because of that
waiting hours for the ambulance waiting
months for cancer treatment
and then when you look at the
environment the conservatives are
letting people down there too allowing
the water companies to pump their filthy
sewage into our Rivers
and failing to meet the promise they
made on policing
commuters across our country are feeling
hemmed in by by criminals they feel that
the anti-social Behavior they're
suffering the burglars is just
unacceptable let the conservatives are
allowing too many criminals to get away
with it all this must change
but the conservative government are out
of touch they're out of ideas and they
are out of excuses
yeah and on the 1st of May let's all
send a message to these conservatives
it's time that they were out of
government too
[Applause]
and that's why so many people across the
country are turning to the liberal
Democrats
they know that the liberal Democrats
work hard for their communities hear
their concerns never take them for
granted
and in this part of the world we've been
having some success on the basis of that
hard work let's remember that historic
by-election just across the county in
buckinghamshire in Cheshire Amazon where
Sarah Green beat the conservatives
[Applause]
and let's look at Watford where our
amazing Peter Taylor got re-elected as a
mayor of Watford
and how not only did we win Saint Albans
Council we we won it again and that time
with 50 councils counselors out of 54.
amazing
and it's not just here in Hertfordshire
where where our campaigns are winning
and we're going to win even more this
may it's across the country too from
Stockport to Surrey from Eastbourne to
Isha from Horsham to Hull
liberal Democrat campaigns are going
from strength to strength
and when we're knocking on those doors
we're finding that lifelong
conservatives are saying they've had
enough they're never going to vape
conservative again and they're switching
to the liberal Democrats
people who usually vote labor are
feeling often let down by their local
labor counselor and their local labor
councils and they're switching to the
liberal Democrats and let's remember
but it was the local elections last May
when it was the liberal Democrats who
made more gains than any other party
across the country
so as we look to the elections this
coming may I believe liberal Democrats
are also going to make many many more
gains
and you know
um that success
I think is so important
and let's just remember why it's so
important we're finding that people want
those liberal Democrat champions in
their local area fighting their
Community strong liberal Democrat local
Champions they want strong liberal
Democrat councils to deliver a fair deal
and if we make these gains we'll have a
strong base for getting more liberal
Democrats elected to Parliament of the
next general election
so let's go out there let's campaign and
let's win thank you very much
[Applause]